I'd love to hear your thoughts on risk
and failure whoo yeah thoughts on risk
in failure I think that both are vital
so I think you should continually risk
and you will fail and when you do you
have to get back up and you have to try
again because that's the only way that
you're going to succeed and the and true
failure is when you don't get back up
and do it right so failure is not
continuing failure is giving up so there
is no option to fail so with failure do
you think it becomes like a muscle let's
say almost like stage fright and you go
to Toastmasters or something and you you
get better at it
so with failure you're maybe ok with it
more and you've developed sort of
tougher scarier how do you think it
works cuz I've seen it reversed
sometimes where failure just totally
gets people and they don't get back up
yeah well as I said their failure to me
is really not getting back up so that
that is ultimate failure getting back up
and continuing to do something again and
trying again coming up with another idea
another solution is is moving forward
and that is risky and it's hard and
painful sometimes but if you don't get
up and do it again then you failed so I
can see I am you know there are a lot of
examples of people not getting up and
trying again but most of the people that
are successful have gotten up and tried
again and they will continue try again
and they will fail and then they will
continue to try again and if they fail
again they will continue to try again
and that means that they haven't failed
true
city of Los Angeles you said a lot of
people who come here are risk takers did
you feel you were a risk taker when you
came did I say that I was that people
come to us I'm trying to say from my
name maybe you did maybe I just I don't
know if I yeah well I think if people
are coming to Los Angeles to be in the
film industry that is definitely taking
a chance that's definitely but you you
have a goal you have a desire and
something to achieve and if you can
remain focused which is very hard
especially in an industry that is filled
with rejection constant constant
rejection in every field and it's it's
it's a very very difficult industry but
if you can continue in it then you will
you will be successful you just have to
stay focused and keep trying keep trying
keep trying keep trying and ultimately
hopefully get that job yeah hopefully
you you have to be good so keep keep
working at your skill sure so I think
it's difficult to because no one usually
gives you notes on why you didn't get it
I mean it's sometimes they do but
oftentimes you don't and it's all across
the board from whatever it is yeah so
there's not script notes or someone's
saying you know we liked you but no so
you don't know what it is and it is
actually quite difficult just coming
from the filmmakers stand my side of
things because I watch a lot of
auditions and we make decisions and my
mother's also a model so so I come from
that world where she constantly goes
through rejection and has for her entire
life and while she's a very successful
model she's rejected continually and you
have to sort of been able to watch that
and and see how she just keeps going
okay next okay next and then from my
side of things as the director I will
look at actors and I'll go well you
might be good but you don't look the
part but they until I can't hire you so
just so it's initially it's it's all
it's so subjective and so if I then get
an agent who comes back to me and says
can you give me feedback which many
times they do
if I can give feedback I'll go but keep
in mind if I audition 200 people I can't
give feedback for 200 people I don't
have that kind of time at all so it's
not that I didn't like you very likely
that if you if you are in a room
auditioning for me there is something
about you that I like and so you've made
it there well done congratulations to
you keep going you're in the room so you
made it there that that should be that
should be acknowledgement enough that
while you didn't get this part there
were 200 people that were going for the
same part as you and only one of you can
get it so 199 people will be rejected
but 199 people still made it into the
room I still recognize them there's a
couple of actors that I go every single
movie I go ah let's see if we can put
them in this role no no it's not gonna
work
unfortunately and so they're contacted
constantly and said hey maybe you'll be
in this role and then they're not and
it's not anything other than it could be
timing it could be hair color it could
be AI color it could be the author
wasn't a big fan or you're too tall for
the female actor or too short for the
female actor or or you know I mean if
there are so many different aspects that
go into it that have nothing to do with
your ability to perform so that's all I
have to say the actors keep going keep
doing it
you